[Music]
[Applause]
all right kids today we're gonna read
the biography of Nick Saban who it
starts off with a quote from Nick Saban
himself football is not Hamlet it's not
tragedy it should be fun tell it to your
face Saban who was then the head coach
of the Dolphins had publicly denied any
interest in the Alabama job over and
over and over well guess I can close the
book there's no way he's going to
Alabama a man is only as good as his
word
see even knew how would look if he left
the Dolphins after just two seasons he
would be called a liar a failure and a
quitter say it with me kids Adel but the
decision wasn't his alone yes it was
nobody gives a sh a what your wife
thinks Wayne we think it was paying you
millions of dollars you don't even give
a about your wife you know why she
wanted out she felt ugly in Miami and if
you want to feel smart sexy and special
you surround yourself with thousands of
toothless townies in Tuscaloosa she also
believed that a college town was a much
healthier place to raise their two
children dan his daughter Kristin almost
murdered someone with her bare hands yes
yes she did
Saban says in the NFL you were penalized
for success what success exactly the
only thing is smaller than his Hitler
stashes Nick Saban's dick
that overinflated football fan of sting
ran he eats sleeps eats and breathes
Mississippi State stingray got Internet
famous for hooting hollering about one
of the worst teams and one of the most
top-heavy overrated conferences of all
time the SEC the Southeastern Conference
or KKK for short it's like the NFL for
garbage States too poor to support a pro
team if you're not sure which schools
are part of the SEC Google most
uneducated states or states with the
highest rate of uninsured adults or
hardest places to get an abortion the
only thing the SEC hates more than gay
marriage is the forward pass if it
weren't for college football SEC fans
would never know college existed someone
needs to tell these simpletons they've
got three sets of tigers two sets of
Bulldogs and one team named after a
woman's period I stingray I got one more
surprise for you before the big game the
Bulldogs are gonna let me return a
kickoff no I got rid of the South's most
hateful statue you tore down Robert II
lady hell no I tore down Nick Saban
statue over Tuscaloosa no 5-foot tall
man deserves a statute what'd you do
with it I melted it down sculpted it
into a real southern hero
[Music]
there she is stingray in all her majesty
you were born to be bronzed
there's no secret that I think Nick
Saban is a horrible human and it doesn't
help that he just hired that whiny
arrogant beautiful Lane Kiffin so
imagine my delight when I found out Lane
and his lovely wife have a public access
show
[Music]
welcome back you're on triple K what's
your question hey Lane just wondering if
it's natural talent or if you guys
practice fumbling all the time
you stupid pieces all right I'm gonna go
cheers inside your Tramp of a watch
no pain no Lane next caller I love what
you've done open up the offense and give
the tide an identity as a passing team
and I was wondering what Nick Saban's
oatmeal cream pies taste like when he
gets them in your mouth you coward War
Eagle you you look maybe we start
screening some of these calls I'd like
to apologize to our viewers
second down let's try again longtime
caller first-time listener big USC fan I
hope you die of AIDS you overpaid
we have got to get a longer cord next
season Who am I kidding we're not gonna
be here next year next dollar what was
it like being the last regrettin al
Davis's 50-year career full of cops I
think your hands are off the air you
looking for brains two-part question now
that you're down south you're gonna
divorce your wife so you can start
farm animals and if you do
divorce your wife you think she'll be
able to handle my big fat after all
those years your pencil dick where are
you gonna be head coach again sweetie no
my love
next caller a nice trophy case you won
Winnie
look out god damn MV better yet where
you gonna bail upward neck I got a
question about the no-huddle offense
okay this one I should be able to handle
why do you think you prefer the hurry up
but every time I fight your smoking-hot
wife in the ass she begged me to slow
down
pretty sure that was Urban Meyer next
caller are you gonna be the next
coordinator to start molesting children
just kidding I know you're really don't
like you next caller Bama fans are all
sister retard
Diana bleep next caller and keep it
clean and don't say a word about my wife
nice tits bitch
hey you wear that visor when your dad
you look Nick Saban now as an Auburn
alum do you have a message for him where
you'll War Eagle that's fun to yell it
is were you at Auburn when those inbred
folks over at Alabama poisoned your tree
I was how did that make you feel
I mean Bama sights memories our Bama it
was that worse than a school shooting do
you think the treatment No I think you
answered